alright guys this is the video you've
been waiting for we're gonna talk about
sneaky hidden ways to make sugar appear
to be healthier than it actually is so a
lot of times when I used to evaluate
people in my clinic and they bring in
their food and we would analyze it ok
now the first thing we would say is well
I'm not eating any sugars ok so then I
look and it's filled with sugars but
sometimes it's packaged in a healthy way
that it doesn't even appear to be sugar
so I'm gonna cover some of the things
that I've run across that appear to be
healthy but they're really not okay the
first one is real cane sugar ok so first
of all like compared to what what what
would be like a fake cane sugar just the
word real makes it a little bit
healthier and then we have brown sugar
right as compared to white sugar so it's
obviously healthier well the difference
between brown sugar and white sugar is
that brown sugar has point zero zero
zero zero one percent molasses in there
so there's a tiny bit of maybe vitamins
and minerals so insignificant that it
really is virtually the same as white
sugar then we have sugar in the raw like
that's a lot better because it's raw
it's still refined sugar ok it's gonna
create the same blood sugar issues then
we have coconut sugar sounds healthier
because it's from coconuts how about
this organic cane sugar because of
course anything that's organic is
healthy fruit juice concentrate because
we know fruit is healthy so it doesn't
really matter if it's concentrated or
not well they're taking this fruit juice
and they're heating it at high
temperatures and you're getting some
massively concentrated sugar without any
nutrients so this is basically sugar
water right here how about this one made
with real fruit yeah they start out with
real fruit but then what do they end up
with after they process it or this one
made with whole grains but that's gonna
be healthier first of all we know that
whole grains are not healthy because
they're going to deplete certain
minerals like zinc because the phytates
not to mention the gluten in there that
destroys your stomach and I guarantee
they're gonna also add refined grains
with
that no one wants to consume purely just
whole grains like sprouted grains or how
about this one
brown rice sugar as compared to white
rice sugar it's the same thing then we
have beet sugar because beets are
healthier well of course the beets are
using our genetically modified so you're
getting the added glyphosate in their
date sugar okay this might have more
vitamins and minerals which is slightly
better but it's still gonna have the
similar glycemic effect honey
same thing it's gonna actually spike
your blood sugars and it has a good
amount of fructose in there as well
maple syrup same deal sounds healthy
it's not Gavin nectar ninety percent of
a gobbet nectar is fructose it's gonna
create a massive problem with insulin
resistance this is actually worse than
high fructose corn syrup as far as
fructose goes barley malt sounds
healthier but it's really not okay
there's a couple other things I want to
talk about sometimes when you see the
total carbohydrates then you have very
little fiber okay chances are you're
gonna have high sugar but sometimes you
don't have high sugar but it's high
carbs like this right here
okay kettles potato chips look on the
back it says that it has 24 grams of
carbohydrate and then we have two grams
of fiber but we have zero sugar so you
might think wow that's healthy right
this is a starch and it's a fried starch
so it's gonna really spike your blood
sugar so you have to understand the
difference between like a starch or like
celery for example usually it's high in
car because the fiber is carbohydrate
that's usually high in fiber low in
sugar but because it's high in fiber
that buffers the carbohydrate and fiber
has no effect on your blood sugar so you
don't worry about that what you have to
worry about is like the starches like
the rice and the potato and also the
ingredients this says potato safflower
oil sunflower oil and or canola okay
I don't like canola oil and it says
right here a hundred percent access
veggie something from our production
process is converted into biodiesel
emits 38% less co2 then petroleum diesel
well uh this that's a good enough reason
right now to buy these chips for me says
right here are natural promised non-gmo
protected verified gluten-free well
everyone knows that there's no gluten in
potatoes no preservatives and zero gram
of trans fats but you know the best way
to know that it's okay to eat is if it
has the word natural okay natural so
anything that has natural on it
go ahead and eat it because it's it's
really good and I hope you guys know I
have a very dry sense of humor and then
I want to talk about serving size you
have serving size and then you have the
number of servings in a box or a
container have an example right here
this gough cookies right here now if you
look at the serving size which is four
cookies that would equal 31 grams of
sugar now that is a lot of sugar but
most people don't stop it for cookies
they keep going
eight this has eight servings so it's
eight times for eight times 31 grams of
sugar so if you consumed all of these in
one sitting you get a massive spike of
sugar so you just have to really watch
the serving size especially when they go
into teaspoons or tablespoons sauces and
things like that they're not measuring
the whole bottle let's see what this
says right here this says just a handful
of natural ingredients
hey sugars natural no artificial colors
flavors or preservatives that's what I
was really concerned about the colorings
non-gmo and it's vegan friendly wow this
is awesome
okay do you got cookies right there now
when you consume food with sugar and
protein and fat especially if it's
cooked as in ice cream
an average ice cream has about 34 grams
of sugar has protein in there that's
milk sugar plus a lot of fat and they
cook that you're going to get a much
more
exaggerated spike in insulin not to
mention something called glycation which
really caused these proteins to morph
into this really sticky protein that
cool clog things up in your body yogurt
especially the sweetened filled with
sugar just tons of sugar and yogurt even
the plane has a lot of sugar and then
you have the breakfast bars again read
the ingredients you're gonna find a lot
of sugar granola bars they might appear
to be healthy because granola is healthy
right tons of sugar but like I said
before this is what I use to know if
something's healthy if it says natural
alright thanks for watching if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos